so we're here today at Oak Tree Gun Club
and we're gonna shoot a bunch of stuff
that you see utilized in movies or that
you just have around your house to see
what's actually bulletproof disclaimer
we're here with professionals in a safe
environment do not try this at home
we're testing it for you
today we are going to be using the 22
long rifle round which is a lighter
bullet that travels very fast we're
gonna be using a nine-millimeter Luger
and we are going to be using a 460 Smith
& Wesson Magnum what does the most
damage at 460 cans because it's the
biggest it's the longest casing with the
most powder behind it it's also the
heaviest bullets you get a lot of weight
with a lot of velocity 95% of stuff you
see in movies it's no it doesn't wear a
bunch of liars for the most part we're
gonna try and shoot a cast-iron skillet
with a nine millimeter and a 460 Smith &
Wesson the four sixes Kate is gonna go
home without a skillet sorry oh that
went through nope
what do we know oh yeah oh yeah I did
[Music]
Jules got two holes 9-millimeter hit it
almost in a bullseye
I actually thought the nine would bounce
off of it we went right through
turns out cast iron skillet not a great
shield noted it's time to shoot an
iPhone we're gonna shoot it with a
9-millimeter gun we've only got one shot
[Music]
i phone didn't survive the front doesn't
look so bad the back looks pretty we're
gonna shoot a card or my prediction is
that it will stop the 22 that looks like
it went through so this is the 22 hole
that's the 9 hole and this is the 469
where the 22 who also went through
that's crazy all three of them went
through the door get out of your car so
we're gonna shoot a table because I feel
like in every movie if you always see
people hiding behind tables and this one
you get to shoot again go ahead and pick
those up keep your fingers off the
trigger go ahead watch your barrels
you're gonna take aim at that table
everybody's got eyes and ears on and one
two three
that was Gustav after all we've seen
today the chairs probably not gonna stop
over it so he might as well just put a
bunch of a minute
[Music]
so guns work what we learned today was
that guns do their jobs and movies are
fake but I feel like we probably knew
that already but you don't need to
squeeze the gun I'm talking to you I've
got a very soft touch uh-huh tell that
to that rav4 you probably ripped it
right off the car